nos preguntan cuáles de estas rectas son
paralelas rectas paralelas son rectas
que tienen la misma pendiente son rectas
distintas y que nunca se intersecta
tenemos que buscar entonces rectas que
son distintas y que tienen la misma
pendiente para nuestra fortuna todas
estas rectas que están en la forma igual
a m x + b o forma pendiente ordenada así
es que para todas estas rectas
simplemente por inspección vamos a
determinar la pendiente entonces para la
recta a tenemos que la pendiente es
igual a 2 aquí la tenemos la pendiente
de la recta es igual a 2 para la recta
de la pendiente es igual a 3 la
pendiente de la recta es igual a 3 estas
dos primeras rectas no son paralelas las
vamos a graficar en un momento para que
las veamos pero no son paralelas para la
recta se lo va a poner en púrpura la
pendiente es igual a 2 la pendiente de
la recta se es igual a 2 entonces
tenemos que la recta c y la recta son
paralelas pues tienen la misma pendiente
y son rectas distintas pues su ordenada
el origen es diferente platiquemos
entonces estas rectas
primero la recta a la recta que pasa por
0,6 así 123456 el punto 0.6 y la
pendiente es 21 a la derecha 2 para
arriba 1 a la derecha
2 para arriba 2 a la derecha 4 para
arriba estamos sobre la misma recta
otros dos para la derecha 4 para arriba
4 para arriba y ahí ya tenemos
suficientes puntos para trazar la línea
trazamos entonces la línea que une esos
puntos
aquí tenemos esa línea recta y déjame
hacer la mejor déjame tratar de hacerla
más recta aquí la tenemos
es lo mejor que lo puedo hacer esta es
la recta a tracemos la recta de la recta
b tiene ordenada el origen menos 6
también pasa por el punto cero menos 6
nada más que la pendiente en este caso
es 3 es una mayor pendiente ahora sí que
mola entonces cuando x avanza 1 se eleva
en 3
cuando x avanza en dos y se eleva en 62
46 cuando x avanza en dos y se eleva en
6 entonces tenemos la recta déjame
dibujar lo más recto posible aquí lo
tenemos y aquí la tenemos es una recta
con una mayor pendiente cuando x se
incrementa en 1 el crecimiento en jet
para esta recta en azul es mucho mayor
que para la recta roja aquí tenemos la
recta de estas dos rectas intersectan
por lo cual definitivamente no son
paralelas
finalmente la recta c que tiene una
ordenada del origen de 5 vamos a
ubicarla uno dos tres cuatro cinco aquí
la tenemos el punto cero cinco y la
pendiente es de dos avanzamos en uno
para x y elevamos en dos para iu si
disminuyes en uno para x vas a disminuir
en dos para ello tiene la misma relación
la misma relación que teníamos aquí de 2
a 1 es la misma que menos 2 a menos uno
hacemos lo mismo trazamos varios puntos
con esa pendiente disminuimos en dos
para x tenemos que disminuir en cuatro
para i
44 para y déjame ubicar otro punto más
ya tenemos un número suficiente de
puntos vamos a trazar la recta ce así
que uniendo estos puntos obtenemos la
recta se nota que la recta a y la recta
c nunca se interceptan tienen la misma
pendiente tienen distinta ordenada el
origen pero tienen la misma pendiente se
están incrementando a la misma razón
pero nunca se van a interceptar es por
eso que las rectas a y c son rectas
paralelas